yes I believe in the Internet I believe
it will get increasingly popular and
we're doing some neat new things to take
advantage of that when you have the
level of success that we've had when you
have a business that's important as this
with this many competitors you're going
to have people saying some nasty things
the lives all over the world should be
treated with the same value that we
treat lives here in the in the rich
world if you ask people across the
United States is the future going to be
better than the past most say no he's an
American entrepreneur author investor
and philanthropist in 1975 he co-founded
Microsoft which went on to become the
world's largest PC software company he's
currently the richest person in the
world with an estimated net worth of 84
billion dollars
he's Bill Gates and here's my take on
his top ten rules of success volume 2
rule number 2 is my personal favorite
and stick around all the way to the end
for a special bonus clip and as always
as bill is talking if we said something
that really resonates with you please
leave in comments below and put quotes
around it other people could be inspired
as well enjoy
[Music]
and so you really have to believe the
Internet's going to be mainstream a lot
of people are going to get out there and
use it and that they're going to be
willing to pay for some content is that
the operating idea that you have well
each of these businesses is an
entrepreneurial business the
overreaching theme is that yes I believe
in the Internet I believe it will get
increasingly popular and we're doing
some neat new things to take advantage
of that if you've got a lot of cash on
hand yes right all right it puts you in
an into position you can experiment with
a lot of entrepreneurial ideas and see
what sticks and what's lies well we're
in business to make money and but the
other thing is providing such a cash
flow for you well it all belongs to the
shareholders
we're not dilettante oh I know we are
business people and it is true that if
you find an idea that requires three or
four years of improvement and patience
and really sticking with it that we're
very good at that take Windows which we
bet our company on everybody who doubted
that would succeed IBM did not support
us in that it took longer than we
expected over four years before finally
graphical interface got popular and now
people take it for granted it's part of
every personal computer and you just you
just expect it to be there that was one
of the grand successes of the company in
the same way we're betting on the
internet that our tools there will be
popular and that a few of these content
plays that we've decided to get involved
in that the scale and and the users will
make those in the great businesses well
certainly every product we do is
absolutely as capable as it can possibly
be you know there's nothing there's no
holding back we are the people at
Microsoft come into work every day
building the best products they can and
they're very proud you go out go into
schools and see how kids are using this
stuff going ask people about how their
jobs have changed because the personal
computer you know we're sitting there
listening to our customers saying
how they'd like to make things better so
we're we do absolutely our best job and
in fact that's why we've been successful
you know anybody who holds back in this
business is going to be around for long
because this is a business where you
always have to be moving at a very rapid
pace you have four years ever since you
were a little boy I have been called a
nerd do you care does it hurt you
well nerd means a lot of things I'm
somebody who can sit and read a book
about science for hours on end and you
know I don't mind being labeled as
somebody who who finds that interesting
there is hardly a day in which something
is not written about Microsoft it has
become almost a frenzy you are being
called the evil empire you forget being
called a nerd you are now being called
arrogant greedy the devil read all this
stuff I heard the distance said what do
you say about all of this what's a very
competitive business and all oh
absolutely when you have the level of
success that we've had when you have a
business that's important as this with
this many competitors you're going to
have people saying some nasty things and
so you have to learn a little bit not to
take it too personally we went to
Harvard and you're dropped out have you
ever thought how your life could be
better off if you had gotten your
Harvard degree well I I'm a weird
dropout because I take college courses
all the time I love learning company
courses and things so I love being a
student and there were smart people
around and you know they fed you and
they gave you these nice grades that
made you feel smart
so I I feel it was unfortunate that I
didn't get to stay there but I don't
think I missed any knowledge because you
know whatever I needed to learn I would
I was still in a learning mode tough
luck or often not always the
pre-synaptic about what we have trying
to do
I remember one in a three-pound where
there are about seven people the date
was with the computer releasing this
character mode thing or would it be
graphic user interface and at the time
to represent a face that was so slow
laugh and writing software so that
window pump oil and so the people are
counting down of it it's kind of a
stupid thing and I'm another believing
this would be great and one of the guys
on the panel said that a bill is wrong
but he'll work harder than the rest of
us but even though it's wrongfully and
weep lightly to succeed and I was the
best pump but I ever happened just by
working day and night I could send you
to scream stuff thunderous but you know
I was an [ __ ] with that period of
time that is I didn't read in vacation I
didn't believe in weekend you know so it
turned out that work for me that we got
our company going into speed a lot of
amazing states bathroom that other
people are in kind of feels and say do
you worry about Linux as a competition
for operating systems yes the you know
there we've competed against various
forms of UNIX over the years and Linux
is a growing in popularity and
definitely a competitor threatening a
competitor well it's a competitor we
take very seriously
I think you know part of Microsoft's
success is that we don't underestimate
the importance of the work that other
companies are doing and so we look out
we you know we think are there aspects
of that that that are best practices for
example online support from the
community things that are done around
Linux are done very well so you know
we're we're thinking about it making
sure that our innovation will make sure
that our value in our leadership stays
in front first I met Warren we're
talking about getting together and doing
something again we pulled out a calendar
and the pages were so blank and I said
wow you know you've managed to avoid
getting tied into a lot of kind of
meaningless activity and Warren said
yeah you have to be good at say no and
picking the things that really make a
difference and that's one of many things
I've learned from warm but that's one of
my favorites and I can blame it on him
whenever I was turning things down you
have made a significant contribution in
the fight against age in Africa you have
funded to a large degree vaccines and
vaccine research give me a sense of
where that's directed in which success
you think we were making and your own
ticular interest in public health in the
world well this is a real passion for me
I thought I'll give us a succinct answer
people I think don't have a full
awareness how four billion of the six
billion people on this planet don't have
basic health needs met the the death
rate of infants the epidemic infectious
diseases that are just a way of life in
most the world don't exist in the in the
developed world and yet the research
isn't going on for the medicines that
would get rid of these diseases even
diseases like tuberculosis where for a
few hundred dollars lives can be saved
that's not being done vaccines aren't
being moved from the rich world to the
poor world AIDS is the most extreme
where the prevention measures that could
prevent this from becoming a huge
epidemic in countries like India
Nigerian many countries where it's not a
huge percentage of the rate which is
about you know the right things I think
are not being prioritized
so the foundation that my wife I have is
have taken as its top priority these
world health issues the research getting
the vaccines out
and it's been fascinating to learn about
this and to try and say that all these
lives the lives all over the world
should be treated with the same value
that we treat lives here in the in the
rich world
so you're just to sum up and essentially
because what you have learned from your
own involvement from funding it in terms
of more money than had ever been applied
is that it can make a difference
absolutely
millions of lives can be and should be
saved through these efforts and you know
we we can make a difference and we can
encourage others to get involved that
was my last question is that happening
as you fund these efforts are you
immediate becoming a kind of wedge that
other governments and other foundations
and other sources a following suit on
matching yeah we've seen a good start I
would say the vaccine fund we put
together we put in seven hundred and
fifty million now governments have
agreed to put up five hundred million in
addition to that in the AIDS area some
of the things we've backed have been
able to attract additional money having
said that this is a cause that somehow
deserves more visibility because when
you talk to people about this and they
hear about malaria or AIDS they really
do care and they think their
government's doing more and so you know
when I'm not working a lot of my
creativity is going into what could be
done to show people that their money
would be well spent it would make a
difference and you know try and make
sure that that world health gets gets
more priority than you can say but
that's what it's all about if you ask
people across the United States is the
future going to be better than the past
most say no my kids will be worse off
than I am they think innovation won't
make the world better for them of their
children so who's right the people who
say innovation will create new
possibilities and make the word world
better
are the people who see a trend toward
inequality and a decline in opportunity
and don't think innovation will change
that the pessimists are wrong in my view
but they're not crazy
if innovation is purely market driven
and we don't focus on the big inequities
then we could have amazing advances and
inventions that leave the world even
more divided
we won't improve public schools we won't
cure malaria we won't end poverty we
won't develop the innovations poor
farmers need to grow food in a changing
climate if our optimism doesn't address
the problems that affect so many of our
fellow human beings then our optimism
needs more empathy if empathy channel's
our optimism we will see the poverty and
the disease and the poor schools we will
answer with our innovation and we will
surprise the pessimists over the next
generation you Stanford graduates will
lead a new wave of innovation which
problem will you decide to solve if your
world is wide you can create the future
we all want if your world is narrow you
may create the future the pessimists
fear I started learning in sweet o that
if we're going to make our optimism
matter to everyone and empower people
everywhere we have to see the lives of
those most in need if we have optimism
without empathy then it doesn't matter
how much we master the secrets of
science we're not really solving
problems we're just working on puzzles I
think most of you have a broader
worldview than I had at your age you can
do better at this than I did if you put
your hearts and minds to it you can
surprise the pessimists we're eager to
see it I mean you're obviously going to
go down in history history books already
said kind of thing but what's the
greatest misunderstand between you and
you
relationship and about each other what
would you say would be this idea of
catfight this idea of what which one of
the many we've kept our marriage secret
for over a decade now Canada that trip
to Canada which I don't think either of
us have anything to complain about in
general and I know that the the projects
like the Mac project you know is just an
incredible thing a fun thing where we
were taking a risk we did look a lot
younger in that video because you look
12 that's what how I try and what was
good but not been fun to work together I
actually kind of miss some of the people
aren't around anymore you know people
come and go in this industry it's nice
when somebody sticks around and you may
have some context of all the things for
the word to not work and the industry
gets all we're all crazy about some new
thing you know like you know the the
there's always this paradigm of the
company that successful is going to go
away and stuff like that it's like to
have people seeing the waves and waves
of that and yet been willing what I want
to count in to take the risk to bring in
something new as it's been important is
it one last question and then we'll
we'll go to the I know he didn't answer
because the heada said I don't know I'm
not read a secret game area I thought
that was your in thought that wasn't
landed you know when Bill and I first
met each other and work together in the
early days generally we were both the
youngest guys in the room right
individually or together I'm about six
months older than he is but roughly the
same age and now when we're working at
our respective companies I know about
you but I'm the oldest guy in the room
most of the time and that's why I love
being here
and happy to oblige happy to oblige and
you know I think of I think if most
things in life as either a Bob Dylan or
a Beatles song but there's that that one
line and that one Beatles song you and I
have memories longer than the road that
stretches out ahead and that's that's
clearly true here and well you know what
I think we should end us there let's
just end it there
Romano's here right here thank you
thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for watching this
is an experimental video doing a volume
2 of a top 10 rule so I'm curious to
figure out did you guys like this you
want me to do more like this in the
future or not leave in the comments
below let me know I also curious to
figure out which of the rules if you
like the best what is most applicable to
your life or to your business right now
what immediate change are you going to
make after watching this video leave in
the comments and I'm going to join in
the discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout at the tuan million thank
you so much for picking up ten copies of
my book your one word and sharing it
with some of your friends and clients I
really really really really appreciate
it so thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is
much love I'll see you soon
even in the early days if you said a
computer on every desk in every home and
you'd say ok how many homes are there in
the world how many deaths are there in
the world you know can I make 20 bucks
for every home 20 bucks for every desk
you know you get these big numbers but
part of the beauty of the whole thing
was we were very focused on the here and
now should we hire one more person if
our customers didn't pay us would we
have enough cash to meet the payroll you
know we really were very practical about
that next thing and so involved in the
deep engineering that we didn't get
ahead of ourselves we never thought you
know how big we'd be I remember when one
of the early list of wealthy people came
out and one of the Intel founders was
there the guy around winged computers
actually was still weighing was still
doing well and we thought boy if the
software business does well now that a
Microsoft could be similar to that but
it wasn't a real focus they the everyday
activity of just doing great software
threw us in and some decisions we made
like the quality of the people the way
we were very global the vision of how we
thought about software that was very
long-term but you know other than those
things you know we just came into work
every day and wrote more code and you
know hired hired more people it wasn't
really until the IBM PC succeeded and
perhaps even until Windows succeeded
that there was a broad awareness that
Microsoft was very unique
as a software company that these other
companies had been one product companies
haven't hired people couldn't do a broad
set of things didn't renew their
excellence dint do research so you know
we thought we were doing something very
unique but it was easily not until 1995
or even 1997 that that there was this
wide recognition that we we were the
company that had had revolutionized
software